well we begin this bulletin with
breaking news from ethiopia al jazeera
has obtained satellite imagery that
shows the united arab emirates is now
providing military support to the
ethiopian army the investigation has
revealed the uae hired two private
companies from europe to run military
flights to ethiopia
the images also show drones at an
ethiopian airport in the capital addis
ababa
well let's now bring in samuel getachu
he's an ethiopian journalist and he
joins us now live from the capitol
samuel we obviously know eritrea got
involved in this conflict very early on
and now seemingly the uae just what do
we know about foreign involvement that's
taking place on the side of the
government
well the prime minister has been saying
that he's willing to work with friendly
nations
uae has been supporting some of the
reforms of this prime minister from the
get-go they provided funds when the
ethiopia was running out of forex for
instance um and this is no surprise but
um ethiopia is obviously receiving
support
from the so-called friendly nations
including turkey that have
provided military assistance to the
country this came about after the prime
minister visited
uh turkey which is uh one of the biggest
foreign investors in the country and
signed a military agreement with the
with the president of turkey and this is
no surprise
sammy we've obviously seen a huge
recruitment drive as well um and between
the call to defend the capital addis and
the roundups we've been hearing about of
tigriens what's the situation like in
the capital at the moment
well um
at uh and at this above per se there has
been a movement of young people that are
being recruited that are coming out and
saying we want to be part of the
ethiopian army this came about after the
prime minister literally announced on
monday night saying he's about to join
the battleground and he is heading to
the battleground but that has since been
confirmed by the spokesperson of the
ethiopian government
and he said that the prime minister is
indeed in the battleground offering
leadership to some of the soldiers of
ethiopia that have been fighting with
against the tplf for almost a year but
what we also know for a fact at this
hour is that the police chief of deborah
brahan which is
about 120 kilometers away from adi sabha
have told all citizens to carry their
ids and they'll be telling the idps to
stay in the shelters and they have also
arrested the police chair
because he has been
not willing to detain or arrest uh you
know people that have been uh suspected
of supporting the tplf
samuel 120 kilometers doesn't sound very
far away at all i'm curious how strong
are the forces heading towards the
capital at the moment we obviously know
a number of other factions are also
involved
yeah the oromo liberation front as part
of
the tplf they've
you know somehow managed to find a
common enemy in this european prime
minister and the ethiopian government
they've been
you have to know the background
information on the relationship between
the ttl while they were in government
they had the oil left has been fighting
the tpnf dominated coalition government
for the last 27 years before this prime
minister came to power so the
relationship between them is to really
defeat the prime minister and see
arranged a change of government in addis
ababa but we exactly don't know how
successful they are but however the olf
has been saying that they're near addis
ababa they've been saying it for the
last few weeks they're about to come to
adi salvador but that was proven to be
wrong but with the tplf they've been
there was
the last last night there was a zoom
meeting that was leaked by a canadian
activist
saying that they're looking for some
kind of transition government
in ethiopia and
but that has since their demands have
been changing
you know ever since they've begun to get
closer to addis ababa even that was
recognized by the u.s envoy that visited
ethiopia saying that their demand is
increasing
putting in doubt the kind of compromise
that needs to take place to end this
conflict that began a year ago and again
affected millions of you
sam you'll get a two there with all the
latest for us from the capital addis
ababa thanks so much samuel